montenegro on the sparkling adriatic
coast in the 1980s it was a magnet for
the rich and famous the country is
hoping to build on that legacy in recent
years several luxury hotels have emerged
along the coast that's led to a huge
demand for water many of the coastal
cities have invested in modern water
infrastructure now there are plans to
treat the wastewater to a pump station
is under construction behind the hotels
in hatcheck Novi it will discharge the
treated sewage from the wastewater
treatment plant into the ocean busty
german engineer yo MC Joe is in charge
of the site the aim is to prevent
untreated water from finding its way
into the ocean setting up an efficient
water and wastewater treatment system
will cost some 150 million euros the
country's biggest investment in 30 years
a large portion is financed by Germany's
International Development Bank the KfW
jet Coelho de vich is overseeing the
water infrastructure projects for the
KfW and Montenegro this sea outfall pipe
has to be laid on the seabed before the
tourist season begins this is a
discharge pipeline for the treatment
plant through which treated sewage is
pumped into the ocean at a depth of 35
meters divers are to fasten the pipes on
the ocean floor in a few days the
beaches will be full of tourists tourism
is montenegro's biggest revenue source
but more tourists also means higher
power consumption electricity comes from
Montenegro zinter land the country's
largest hydropower plant is located at
the piva reservoir the damn walls are
200 metres high but the facility is
outdated and is being retrofitted with
the help of a KfW loan managed by
Djokovic the staff leg is steam rises
yeah the power plant is 37 years old
even with the best maintenance its life
cycle is at an end it can't do certain
things that means the security of the
plant is the priority in second place
extending its lifespan and the most
important is eco friendliness
means generating green electricity green
power means fewer carbon emissions once
it's retrofitted the power plant can
produce even more clean energy for that
to happen all the turbines have to be
switched off one after the other and
retrofitted it's not easy because the
water pressure is very high in the
control room the technicians are nervous
hoping everything will work out smoothly
the first turbine is now stationary and
ready for retrofitting even the control
system is to be replaced completely the
modernized power plant will be able to
supply green electricity to coastal
towns over the next few years in the old
town of kotor tourist groups have
already arrived many more are on the way
they can expect clean water and reliable
power supply and especially in the newly
built yacht harbours and luxury hotels
tourists also expect a high
environmental standard